j'espère que j'aurai pas plus les noirs
et de lashkar gah du soleil orage qui
arrive périclès toujours tout fait à
trouve à la casse faire ce que tu veux
le camp pour le pas pour faire un
contre-jour descendu la ligue phase les
affronter
ça compte
la fréquence est reçu au caire
on va tourner par la droite tout ce
temps
portugais enfants dans le pearl un
merdier n'a pas encore à votre jour de
restaurer planquer
pékin 7 dans le port en paix en contre
jour là la porte noire de valeur à
l'effectif
on va devant doucement lavande ou trois
ans devant
frêche moyens tout sur mon écran je
l'espère en avant tout doucement vers la
banque est
la fa sur loana dans l'aude la texture
au revoir le feu
voila voila c'est vachement taux se
situe après voilà voilà un peu sur ta
gauche voilà c'était un peu dans les
volutes elle préférerait et ça continue
comme ça c'est un type en pot
car c'est un peu plus parce que vous
aviez très étroit voilà
c'est pas joli que des centaines un peu
sur ma gauche est déjà un peu un tout
petit peu moins forts c'est peu quand
même à la télé on arrive on va arriver
au cou sarko sur le voilà qu'on va
remonter sur le truc cela devait arriver
sur un père à l'âge des banderoles ces
débats la dette va monter sur la plage
où arrive le grand cordel où en était
hier à la cour avait arrivée - les
payeurs à peu près que
car c'est là où on finirait sur les
souris c'est sur les tracteurs c7
voilà exactement où les payeurs voilà
voilà